Celine Dion takes on her body shamers
you look so strong and you are so strong
this is the courage tor but sometimes
the tabloids and sometimes the critics
have come after you what do you say to
those people who are being critical of
your body lately is there anything wrong
about my body when I was 12 years old my
face was rounder because you have more
fat in your you're younger but I've
always been very thin if you don't want
to be criticized you are in the wrong
place
today the 51 year old singer announced
she's postpone the next four nights of
her world tour because of a throat virus
quote Celine is on strict doctor's
orders to take one week of rest to fully
recover
despite the postponement Celine actually
just extended her courage world tour
into September of 2020 and she dropped a
new video that's the Grammy winner
wiping off her makeup in her video
imperfections the black and white
footage showcases the leans love of
fashion up couture custom-made just for
Celine how does she do it well we've
seen Celine with her BFF Pepe munos
together in the front row of fashion
shows that's where he and stylist sydney
lopez get a lot of ideas
what is it like to have that
relationship with her because she said
icon just so many people we forget that
Celine Dion what song would you think of
if you got to buy a fabulous pair of
shoes I don't need to say any song
the shoes are singing from singing they
call in my lane call your name I want
those shoes
any size they come oh not what size them
it doesn't matter from 5 to 10 I'll make
you work Sun shoes one then malls and we
add that to the tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]